hello folks
there you go Mr secretary
let me Begin by saying I know there are
millions of Americans millions of
Americans in this country who feel
disappointed and uh discouraged or even
a little bit angry but the course
decision today on student debt
and I must admit I do too
before I tell you the steps we're going
to take and want to talk about will be
enabled I want to talk about what we're
able to achieve so far
on student loan over the past few years
first we made the largest increase in
Petal grants in over a decade helping
students from families who nearly all
make less than sixty thousand dollars a
year
then we fix the so-call with the help of
the Department Public service loan
forgiveness program
so the borrowers who got into public
service such as school teachers police
officers social workers service members
uh you know they actually got the debt
relief they interview entitled into the
law
before I came to office only 7 000
people have benefited from that program
today over 600 000 borrowers have
received relief from that program
and it's still available
so many people more so many more people
can be helped and I encouraged you to
apply if you haven't already you're
still eligible to go to studentaid.gov
it matters
third my Administration improved the
program from the Obama Biden
Administration on income driven
repayment plan that's what it was
referred to as
back then we set a limit
student borrowers would pay no more than
10 percent of their disposable income
to pay back their debt in any one time
my Administration is going to reduce
that to 5 percent
it's now the most generous repayment
program ever no one with an
undergraduate loan today or in the
future whether from a community college
or a four-year College will have to pay
more than five percent of disposable
income
repay their loan and that's income after
you pay for the Necessities like housing
and food and the like
typical bar is going to save about a
thousand dollars a year
and if you keep up payments for 20 years
without missing them your total debt is
Forgiven after 20 years that's what the
program was before but we've just
reduced it five percent
in addition to that last year I
announced my student debt relief plan
a plan that was on the verge of
providing more than 40 million Americans
with real debt relief
up to ten thousand dollars for many
borrowers and up to twenty thousand for
those who has gotten a Pell Grant nearly
90 percent of their leave have gone to
borrowers ninety percent of it making
less than seventy five thousand dollars
a year and no one no one making over 125
000 would qualify
this program was all set to begin the
website had been set up the applications
had been simplified so that it took less
than five minutes to complete notice had
been sent out to people about the relief
they were eligible for 16 million people
16 million people have already been
approved the money was literally about
to go out the door and then Republican
elected officials and special interests
stepped in they said no no literally
snatching from the hands of millions of
Americans thousands of dollars in
student debt relief that was about to
change their lives
you know these Republican officials just
couldn't bear the thought of providing
relief for working class middle class
Americans
Republican state officials sued my
Administration
attempting to block relief including
millions of their own constituents
republicans in Congress voted to
overturn the plan I think everyone I
don't think I had any Republican votes
for this plan
at the same time think about this
we all supported the paycheck Protection
Program remember PPP
you know which was designed to help
business owners who lost money because
of the pandemic it was a worthy program
but let's be clear some of the same
elected Republicans members of Congress
who strongly opposed can release the
students got hundreds of thousands of
dollars themselves and really members of
Congress
because of the businesses they were able
to keep open
several members of Congress got over a
million dollars
all those loans are forgiven you know
how much that program cost
s
760 billion dollars
my program's too expensive
360 billion dollars more than I proposed
in my student debt relief program
I was trying to provide students with
ten to twenty thousand ten to twenty
thousand dollars Relief by comparison
the average amount of forgiven in the pp
people the pandemic Loan program average
amount forgiven was seventy thousand
dollars
our kid making
60 000 bucks
trying to pay back his bills
asking for ten thousand dollars in
relief
come on hypocrisy is stunning
it can't help a family making 75 grand a
year but you can help a millionaire and
you have your debt forgiven
my plan would not only have life and
life change for Muslim Americans would
have been good for the American economy
freeing millions of Americans with a
crushing burden of student debt more
homes have been bought more business
would have been started more couples
would have had the confidence to start a
family millions of people would have
felt they could get on with their lives
these Republicans blocked all that now
in addition to the hypocrisy some of
these Republican Comics were shamelessly
pushing to advance the bill in the
coming weeks that gives hundreds of
billions of dollars in tax breaks and
handouts to the wealthiest Americans
they still haven't given up on making
permanent a two trillion dollar tax cut
that they never paid for
never paid for
two trillion dollars
so let me be clear for republicans in
Congress it's not about reducing the
deficit it's not about fairness and
forgiving loans it's only about
forgiving loans they have to pay
today the Supreme Court sided with them
I believe the Court's decision to strike
down my student debt relief program was
a mistake was wrong
I'm not going to stop fighting to
deliver borrowers what they need
particularly those at the bottom end of
the economic scale
so we need to find a new way
and we're moving as fast as we can
first I'm announcing today A New Path
consistent with today's ruling to
provide student debt relief to as many
borrowers as possible as quickly as
possible
we will ground this new approach in a
different law than my original plan the
so-called Higher Education Act that that
will allow secretary Cardona who's with
me today
to compromise waive or release loans
under certain circumstances
this new path is legally sound it's
going to take longer and in my view it's
the best path that we managed to
providing for as many bars possible with
debt relief I'm directing my team to
move as quickly as possible under the
law just moments ago secretary Cardona
took the first step to initially to
initiate that new approach we're not
going to waste any time on this we're
getting moving on a race it's going to
take longer but we're getting at it
right away second we know what many
borrowers will need to make their hard
choices which they're which their
budgets are be a strained now when they
start to repay their monthly loan
payments this fall
you know we know that figuring out how
to pay these ad expenses can take time
for borrowers and they might miss
payments at the front end
as they get back into repayment normally
this could lead bars to fall into
delinquency and default
but without their financials it will
hurt their Financial Security and that's
not good for them or the economy
that's why we're creating a temporary
12-month what we're calling on-ramp
repayment program
now it's about the same as a student
loan pause
it's been in effect for the past three
years
monthly payments will be due bills will
not go out and interests will be
accruing and during this period if you
can pay your monthly bills you should
but if you cannot if you miss payments
this on-ramp will temporarily remove the
threat of the fall or having your credit
harm which can hurt borrowers for years
to come
because the Department of Education
won't refer borrowers the reason why
that will work they won't refer
borrowers who Miss payments to Credit
Agencies for 12 months to give them a
chance to get back up and running
let me close to this
a republican officials say student loan
relief is a giveaway to the privilege
you hear that loud now the privileged
I love the concern for the privilege but
I know who student loan borrowers are in
this country so it all you
with a couple
putting off having a child until they
can find their way to deal with their
debt
that's who they are very young putting
all behind their first home so they can
get out from under student loans
Hope on the horizon thanks to relief
that I planned last year today's Court
decision statuted away from I get it I
get it I hear this
it's and I'm concerned about but today's
decision has closed One path now we're
going to pursue another
I'm never going to stop fighting for you
we'll use every tool at our disposal to
get you the student debt relief you need
and reach your dreams it's good for the
economy it's good for the country it's
going to be good for you thank you very
very much for listening we're going to
get this done God willing thank you Mr
President why did you give millions of
borrowers false hope you've dated
doubted your own authority here in the
past I didn't give any false hope
the question was whether or not if I
would do even more than was requested
what I did I thought was appropriate and
was able to be done and would get done I
didn't give bars also but the
Republicans snatched away the hope that
it was they were given and it's real
real hope thank you Mr President
already did you over Authority I think
the court misinterpreted the
Constitution
president
withdrawal saying there was failure
mistakes doing what they need there was
mistakes during the withdrawal and
before no no all the evidence is coming
back here remember what I said about
Afghanistan I said Al Qaeda would not be
there
I said it wouldn't be there I said we'd
get help from the Taliban what's
happening now what's going on read your
press
I was right
thanks
so so the the report is from the state
department actually about the withdrawal